vous aimez l'odeur de l'herbe fraîche
coupée le souvenir de ces après-midis
d'été après que papa est sorti la
tondeuse bah ce parfum c'est le cri
d'agonie du gazon oui lors d'une
agression les plantes libèrent des coves
ça leur sert à repousser les insectes ou
même prévenir les plantes autour du
danger comme ça elles pourront préparer
leur défense car elles auront des
ressources on l'a vu dans les années 80
en Afrique du Sud des acatias ont fait
mourir de fin des coup dou les troupau
manger leur feuilles et ils n'ont pas du
tout apprécié pour se défendre ils ont
augmenté leur tenur en tanin des
molécules réagissant avec les protéines
des aliments pour former des structures
très difficiles à assimiler les bêtes
avaient beau continuer à manger leur
estomac ne pouvait rien digérer j'ai mal
vous n'êtes pas au bout de vos surprises
des poisons foudroyants au principes
actif les plus puissants la botanique
renferme des secrets terrifiants qu'on
va vous partager ces plantes qui veulent
ta mort mange pas ça c'est empoisonné
petit on me le répétait tout le temps à
croire que la moitié des plantes
sauvages veulent ta mort en fait c'est
surtout que notre corps ne peut pas tout
digérer ce qui est un poison pour nous
ne l'est pas forcément pour une vache il
y avait aussi un peu d'abus une une
diarrhée des douleurs d'estomac oui mais
rarement la mort à coup sûr pourtant il
en existe bien des mortels pour tout le
monde et vous en croisez c'est le cas
par exemple de la grande cigu toutes ces
parties contiennent un mélange de cinq
molécules extrêmement toxiques ce sont
des alcaloïdes des composés constitués
d'azote et de cycles comportant au moins
deux atomes différents tous ne sont pas
dangereux par exemple la caféine ou
encore la morphine s'ils ont des effets
aussi variés c'est à cause de leur
composition ça leur permet de se fixer
sur différents récepteurs de notre
organisme ceux dans la cigu vont cibler
notre système nerveux déréglant les
fonctions autonomes celles sur
lesquelles vous n'avez pas de contrôle
volontaire rythme cardiaque respiration
digestion 0,2 g suffisent à tuer un
adulte en moins d'une heure ça commence
par des vertiges de l'attaque écardie et
des tremblements on ne contrôle plus
rien nos forces nous kitent et notre
système respiratoire se paralyse c'est
un poison très connu car il était déjà
utilisé dans l'Antiquité Socrate est
condamné à en boire à la suite de son
procès ce qui est encore plus dangereux
avec elle c'est sa ressemblance avec une
plante comestible la carotte sa sauvage
alors si vous voulez en goûter demandez
à un expert le monde regorge de plantes
toxiques dans ce genre vous connaissez
sûrement le rissin on en extrait l'huile
du même nom mais aussi la ricine l'arme
préférée d'Eisenberg rassurez-vous
l'huile que vous utilisez n'en contient
plus elle a été retirée heureusement car
elle infiltre vos cellules et les affam
pour fonctionner correctement elles
doivent créer des protéines qui vous
sont utiles c'est le ribosome qui va les
fabriquer il va lire le plan que votre
organisme lui fournit et assembler les
acides aminés nécessaires la ricine va
tout simplement l'empêcher d'interagir
avec l'un d'eux maintenant incapable de
poursuivre la construction votre corps
ne produira plus rien les premiers
symptômes apparaissent au bout de
quelques heures si vous l'avalez si vous
l'avez respiré ou que vous l'injecte
vous pouvez mourir sans le remarquer
mais il existerait un vaccin elle
peut-être brisée par des enzymes et ça
tombe bien on les sécrète en s'injectant
une protéine sensible on pousse notre
corps à en fabriquer plus pour se
défendre il sera donc prêt contre le
poison vous voilà insensible aux
assassinats pour plusieurs mois parfois
les toxines ne sont pas faites pour tuer
mais juste faire souffrir quand j'étais
enfant je suis tombé la tête la première
dans les orties ça a sûrement dû vous
arriver aussi et bien ce n'est rien en
comparaison de cette australienne
pendant une balade à vélo elle tombe
dans la guimpi gimpi elle passera une
semaine à l'hôpital la douleur est
tellement violente que même la morphine
ne parvient pas à l'aider 6 mois plus
tard toujours sous antidouleur elle dira
j'ai eu quatre enfants trois césariennes
et un accouchement naturel aucun d'entre
eux ne s'en rapproche ces feuilles sont
recouvertes de petites aiguilles qui
vont se planter dans la peau elles
contiennent tout un cocktail de
molécules que les scientifiques ont du
mal à caractériser pense qu'il s'agit de
peptide donc de l'amoroïdine le problème
c'est que le mélange est très stable le
poison ne faiblit pas que la plante soit
vivante ou sèche depuis 10 ans donc si
vous laissez une seule aiguille la
douleur peut ressurgir pendant des
années c'est comme se faire brûler
électrocuter à la fois durant votre
douche pendant que vous Dormer un
véritable enfer à tel point qu'un homme
se serait suicidé pour mettre fin au
supplice lui donnant son surnom vous
voulez calmer la douleur il va falloir
verser de l'acide chlorhydrique à 10 %
dessus c'est vous dire à quel point
c'est violent ça n'empêche pas un
habitant d'Oxford for de la cultiver
chez lui comme il s'ennuyait il a pensé
que c'était une bonne idée déclarer
plante la plus douloureuse au monde elle
doit quand même s'incliner face au
mansénilier il POS en Amérique près de
l'équateur et a été surnommé l'arbre de
la mort par les conquistadors touchez
lui va votre peau son écorce et ses
feuilles contiennent des alcaloïde
irritant poser la main dessus entraîne
immédiatement ce genre de blessure le
moindre grain de pollen a le même effet
les conquistadors se sont risqués à
goûter ses fruits car ils ressemble à
des pommes ils l'ont vite regretté les
brûlures vont aussi avoir lieu dans
votre bouche les lèvres vont commencer à
Gon FL et la langue aussi à ce stade les
victimes ont besoin d'une trquéotomie
pour respirer si elles ne sont pas
prises en charge assez vite c'est la
mort assurée vous pensez simplement vous
abriter de la pluie sans le toucher
terrible erreur les gouttes d'eau
ruissellent le long des feuilles et se
chargent en alcaloïde vous allez vous
prendre une pluie d'acide sur le visage
autant couper l'arbre s'il est dangereux
même ça vous ne le pouvez pas sa sève
contient les mêmes composés mais aussi
du forbol un produit utilisé en
recherche biomédicale car permettant le
développement de tumeurs pénètre les
barrières de notre organisme et
suractive une enzyme ça va booster la
division cellulaire et multiplier le
nombre d'erreurs la battre devient donc
très dangereux il faut porter des
protections intégrales pour éviter tout
contact ne pensez pas à le brûler car sa
fumée est toxique elle peut vous rendre
aveugle il a largement mérité son titre
d'arbre le plus dangereux au monde ces
plantes qui peuvent sauver on a retrouvé
une tablette égyptienne vieille de 3500
ans qui liste les maladies et remèdes
connu à l'époque bon ils utilisent des
queu de souris et des excéments c'est
encore un peu magique mais dessus on
retrouve des véritables remèdes c'est
d'ailleurs en étudiant la nature
Hippocrate posa les bases de la médecine
moderne l'un de ces principes la nature
guéit une des plantes les plus utilisées
de cette époque était le silthium il
servait comme épic en cuisine à nourrir
le bétail et permettait de guérir de
nombreuses maladies ça servait même en
contraceptif la plante était tellement
populaire qu'elle apparaît sur la
monnaie de la région de sirène zone où
elle était cultivée malheureusement la
surconsommation et sa zone de culture
très petite ont mené à sa disparition on
ne connaît donc pas sa véritable
puissance mais ça pourrait changer en
2022 un scientifique pense avoir trouvé
deux plantes en Turquie si s'il parvient
à confirmer leur nature et à les
reproduire ell pourrai bien renaître
d'autres peuvent vous venir en aide
parmi les 252 médicaments classés comme
essentiels par l'OMS 28 sont directement
issus de plantes comme l'aspirine
obtenue à partir de la salicine ou
encore la morphine et la codéine tous
deux contenus dans le pavau somnifèr
vous n'avez sûrement jamais entendu
parler des champignons endophyes ils
vont parasiter des racines pour vivre en
symbiose la plante fournit de la
nourriture et le champignon va l'aider
en retour deux d'entre eux produisent
une molécule un peu spéciale le
placlitaxel toxique pour pour les
nuisibles mais également pour les
tumeurs il constitue le taxol un
médicament utilisé en chimiothérapie
comment un champignon peut combattre le
cancer c'est un oneup de Mario lorsque
la division cellulaire commence les
chromosomes se fixent sur des microtubes
ils vont se détruire pour les rétrécir
ça va séparer les deux brins d'ADN et
créer deux cellules le principe actif va
agir comme du ciment en se fixant sur
les fuseaux il empêche la destruction
stoppant la mythose et la prolifération
du cancer c'est le même fonctionnement
pour la vin blastine un alcaloïde issu
d'une fleur la pervenche de de
Madagascar évidemment une fois les
molécules découvertes on les synthétise
en laboratoire bien plus pratique pour
en avoir un stock suffisant surtout ça
évite de détruire une espèce entière
pour se soigner pour obtenir les mêmes
effets qu'un GAM d'aspirine faudrait
infuser 100 g d'écorce de sa pas énorme
mais on produit 40000 tonnes d'aspirine
par an l'espèces ne survivrai pas
surtout que certaines plantes sont
impossibles à cultiver en dehors de
leurs environnements c'est le cas de
celles-ci les indigènes d'Afrique du Sud
la consommaient pour arrêter de manger
durant la chasse elle sécrète une
substance composée de plusieurs sucres
on appelle ça un hétéroside il se fixe
sur l'hippotalamus et bloque la
sensation de faim c'est tellement
puissant que 60 g de plantes suffisent
pour ne plus vouloir manger durant une
journée lorsqu'on injecte le produit à
des rat ça réduit leur consommation de
nourriture de 50 à 60 %. fini
whitewchers c'est ça le produit miracle
pour lutter contre l'obésité sauf que
Cell qui poussent hors du pays ne
produisent rien on ne peut pas non plus
les cultiver là-bas car leur teneur est
trop faible pour être industrialisé
reste la chimie mais même là on y
parvient pas la configuration de la
molécule obtenue n'est jamais la bonne
le produit n'a aucun effet une
entreprise anglaise essaye depuis
1998 encore une preuve que le génie
humain est encore loin d'égaler la
nature ces plantes avec des super
pouvoirs on adorerit en avoir on cherche
tous les moyens de devenir invisible
grâce à la technologie alors qu'une
fleur y arrive juste en utilisant un peu
d'eau ces pétales contiennent des
cristaux blancs responsables de sa
couleur lorsqu'il pleut les gouttes vont
pénétrer les Pors et les solubiliser
elle devient alors invisible comme
lorsque vous mettez du sel dans l'eau il
disparaît en se dissolvant pour
réapparaître elle attend juste de sécher
on dirait un peu une sculpture de glace
non mais il existe un autre moyen de
devenir invisible la métamorphose ce que
fait cette vigne modifiant la forme de
ses feuilles pour ressemblit à celle de
l'arbre sur lequel elle pousse étant
même capable de voir son environnement
oui oui car elle limite les plantes qui
poussent à plusieurs mètres d'elle les
scientifique se pose beaucoup de
questions sur son mécanisme il y a trois
hypothèses déjà les coffres dont on vous
a parlé en intro en captant ceux etmis
autour d'elle elle serait capable de
reconnaître à quelle plante ils
appartiennent décidant ensuite
d'elle-même de changer sa forme la
deuxième serait la présence de bactéries
elles vont récupérer un petit peu du
matériel génétique sur les feuilles pour
ensuite se répandre dans l'air puis se
déposer sur la vigne à ce moment un
nouveau transfert a lieu et les cellules
récoltent les gènes elles s'en servent
ensuite pour se métamorphoser la
dernière option est la capacité qu'elle
a de voir son environnement on sait
depuis longtemps que les plantes possède
des photorécepteurs ça leur permet de
faire la photosynthèse connaître
l'intensité et la direction de la
lumière qu'elles reçoivent c'est grâce à
ça qu'un tournesol connaît la position
du soleil mais est-ce que ça leur permet
de voir pour faire le test la vigne a
été placée à proximité d'une plante
factice pas d'émission COV et pas de
transfert possible verdict ces feuilles
ont changé de forme l'hypothèse est
critiquée dans le domaine scientifique
car l'expérimentation manquait de
rigueur dans le contrôle des paramètres
en plus aucune explication n'est
apportée sur comment la plante serait
capable de voir pourtant c'est
incroyable elle pourrait peut-être même
nous reconnaître grâce à nos phéromon ah
tu es là toi si vous êtes fan de bakugo
on a aussi ce qu'il vous faut un arbre
qui maîtrise les explosions on le
retrouve en Amazonie ses fruits sont de
véritables bombe une fois mur ils vont
perdre de l'eau et devenir de plus en
plus petit sauf qu'ils cherchent à
s'ouvrir en même temps plus ils
rétrécissent plus il y a de la tension
jusqu'à ce que la coque éclate projetant
les capsules et les graines qu'ell
contiennent à 250 km/h parfois à plus de
30 m on parle pas d'un pépin de raisin
regardez ça à une telle vitesse ça peut
vous briser le crâne ça vous donne une
petite idée de ce que fait l'attaque
balgraine si ça ne suffit pas pour
lonigner les intrus il a tout ce qu'il
faut un Tron recouvert de pic pour ne
pas être touché et une sève toxique qui
brûle votre peau elle peut même vous
rendre temporairement aveugle les
aborygènes l'utilisent pour fabriquer
des flèches qui paralysent les poissons
mais de tous les pouvoirs le plus
puissant serait l'immortalité et la
nature nous a créé un véritable Deadpool
tant qu'il reste en morceau il est
capable de se régénérer voilà le Pando
une forêt entière à lui tout seul il
s'agit en fait d'un seul et unique arbre
qui a la capacité de se cloner le
peuplier faux clone tous connectés entre
eux par leur racin lorsqu'un arbre
s'effondre ou que la forêt brûle elles
la font pousser à nouveau tellement
vieux que son âge n'est qu'une
approximation impossible de savoir quand
il a commencé son premier cycle de
naessence son polen lui permet également
de créer d'autres colonies pour
s'étendre en général elles ne font que
400 m² mais celle d'origine en mesure
plus de 400000 m² avec une taille
pareille ça fait du Pando l'organisme
vivant le plus gros au monde on a estimé
son poids total à 6000 tonnes mais
impossible d'être sûr ça représente
quand même 40 baleines vous imaginez un
vilain comme poison ivy prendre le
contrôle de ça c'est la victoire assurée
le monde végétal regorge de spécimens
étranges et l'homme en a également créé
de nouveaux déjà au Néolithique avec la
sélection et l'agriculture permettant la
naissance de nouvelles espèces plus
nourrissantes plus fertiles ou plus
facile à cultiver de nouveaux fruits
également comme la Muroise ou la
clémentine qui sont des hybrides entre
différentes plantes l'utilisation d'OGM
pourrait changer celle qu'on connaît
déjà les rendant plus résistantes plus
puissantes imaginez une forêt de
guimpiipi immortel même si leur
utilisation est controversée il pourrai
se révéler essentiel pour la conquête
spatiale par exemple la NASA est parvenu
à faire pousser une plante à partir de
sol lunaire modifier son ADN lui
permettrait de survivre plus facilement
permettant des cultures et la génération
d'oxygène sur notre AST l'homme pourrait
ainsi s'assurer de coloniser de nouveaux
espaces
habitables